- Good morning Believe Nation,
my name is Evan Carmichael,
my one word is believe and
I believe that entrepreneurs
are going to solve all of
the world's major problems.
So to help you on your journey,
today we're going to learn
how to brace yourself for struggle.
Over to you LeCrae.
(rooster crows)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- I would tell myself, man to
brace yourself for real
struggle, for real pain,
for death, for loss, for hurt.
And then as an artist, I
would tell myself what I say,
I put it on the back of the book too,
if you live for people's acceptance,
you'll die from their rejection.
And that's what I would
tell people because
tell myself, because I was so
worried about being accepted.
These people to accept me,
these people to accept me.
And, when they don't you
die, you crumble inside,
you devastated but, if you
already know who you are,
I feel like I'm made in God's image.
My worth and value cannot be tainted.
You can't add to my worth,
you can't take away from it.
I was born with it,
and so I don't have to
fight for your approval
or your acceptance and I
would want my younger self
to know that, be confident
in who God made me to be
and be the best me I could be.
- So starting a business is
one of the hardest things
you will ever do in your life.
People think it's going to be easy,
but it's one of the hardest things
you will ever do in your life,
no matter how hard you
think it's going to be,
no matter how many videos you watch
of people telling you it's difficult,
it's still way harder and way worse
than what you thought it was going to be.
It just is.
That's life as an entrepreneur.
People will judge you,
people will criticize you,
people will hate on you.
You'll run out of cash faster
than you thought you would.
Customers aren't going
to come through the door
like you thought they would.
The media's not going to cover
you like you thought they would.
Your social media campaign's
aren't going to take off
like you thought you would.
Basically, if you take
whatever idea you had,
and you have a best case, realistic case,
worse case scenario, it's always way worse
than your worse case scenario.
That's just life as an entrepreneur
and I want to be realistic
and share that because I really
struggled at the beginning
and I wasn't prepared for it.
I read magazine articles
and I saw documentaries
of people who had successes
in entrepreneur and I thought,
I can do this, I can
be an entrepreneur too.
And I was prepared to do the work.
I didn't think it would
just be handed to me.
But I wasn't prepared for how
low I would feel about myself.
When I making $300 a month
and I was working and working
and working and not getting any results,
not getting any callbacks,
not getting any people buying
and seeing so little traction,
that I felt at that point,
the lowest I've ever felt in my life.
Because I knew anything
else that I worked on,
I could get some results
with, at school or athletics.
Whatever I worked on, it would improve
and here I was working, and
I wasn't getting any results
and I just felt so low.
I felt worthless, I
felt like I had no value
and I actually told my
business partner that I quit,
at one point.
Because I just felt like I
needed to do something where I
could feel like I'm
contributing something,
because this just sucked.
And I was too embarrassed and too ashamed
to tell other people about it.
My friends would ask me
come out to birthday parties
or beer night or anything
like that and I couldn't.
I always had to say no
because I couldn't afford it.
You know 20 dollars was
too expensive for me.
And so I had to pick one thing
a month that I could go to,
but I would never tell my
friends what was happening.
I would always say that,
I'm living the entrepreneur lifestyle.
I'm just hustling hard on my business.
I was too embarrassed to let
them know what the truth was.
And so I think, part of
what I wanted to share
in this channel is showing the struggles
that people go through to make it.
That it often doesn't
happen in the first year
or two years or three years.
That you have to have a deep
passion for what you're doing,
and just keep doing it and keep
doing it and keep doing it.
And you do it because you enjoy the work.
Because making YouTube
videos is fun for me.
I enjoy being able to reach you guys,
whether I end up hitting
my million subscriber goal
or other big goals that I have or not,
I enjoy doing the work.
And so I think if you
really have a deep passion
for what you're doing,
and expect to struggle,
then you let yourself off
the hook a little bit,
just from an emotional point of view.
That when you don't hit
the results, immediately,
you don't beat yourself up
and feel worthless about it
and you use that as motivation
to go off and do better.
So the question of the
day today is I'm curious,
what was the biggest surprise that you had
as an entrepreneur?
Something that you weren't expecting
but then that happened to you
that you had to deal with
and struggle through.
Really curious to find out.
Share your story in the comments below.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Kelvin Scoon.
Kelvin, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word.
It really, really, really
means a lot to me man,
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys again for
watching, I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is,
much love, and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- That the depth of anybody's struggle
will determine the
height of their success.
And I believe that everything
that I've gone through,
in my whole life, you know,
people ask me what you would change?
I wouldn't change a thing, because
everything that I've gone through
has made me who I am today.
You know, so I'm sitting here
very strong and very confident
and got to love for a
lot of, lot of people.
Jesus struggled and went through things.
Everybody went through they own thing
and people slandered them.
I mean, I feel like if Jesus
can go what he went through,
who am I?
(laughs)
I'm nobody, I'm just a
guy from the hood man,
that just do this music, you know,
but I'm just such a real person,
I don't consider myself
a celebrity at all.
I'm just so real and I love people that,
you know man I just
flow through this thing
and I let my music, I let God guide me,
where he'd like me to go.
But God ain't gon' just guide
you straight to success.
Not God.
He gon' guide you through
a lot of mess, first.
So that when you get the success,
you know how to appreciate
it and you know how to
stay with it and know
how to take care of it
and that's called longevity.
- My biggest challenge of this year,
actually was convincing
members of my own team
that this was a good call.
I'd get kind of called in
front of a group of people
who have known me and
worked with me for years
who would sit down and say,
are you sure you want
to call the album 1989?
We think it's a weird title.
Are you sure that you want to
put an album cover out that has,
less than half of you face on it?
Are you positive, that you want to take
a genre that you have
cemented yourself in,
and completely switch to a new one that
you are a newcomer to?
And answering all those
questions with, yes I'm sure,
that was I think something, that
really frustrated me at the time,
like guys don't you understand?
I promise, this is what I'm dying to do.
The biggest kind of struggle
turned into the biggest triumph
when it worked out.
- When I was seven and
a half, I was raped.
I won't say severely
raped, all rape is sever.
The rapist,
was a person very well known to my family.
I was hospitalized.
The rapist was let out of jail
and was found dead
that night, and the police suggested,
that the rapist had been kicked to death.
I was seven and a half.
I thought that I had
caused the man's death
because I had spoken his name.
That was my seven and
a half year old logic.
So I stopped talking, for five years.
Now to show you again,
how out of evil there can come good,
in those five years, I read every book
in the black school library.
I read all the books I could get
from the white school library.
I memorized James Weldon
Johnson, Paul Laurence Dunbar,
Countee Cullen and Langston Hughes.
I memorized Shakespeare, whole plays,
50 sonnets.
I memorized Edgar Allen
Poe, all the poetry.
Never having heard it.
I memorized it.
I had Longfellow, I had Guy
de Maupassant, I had Balzac.
Rudyard Kipling.
I mean it was Catholic kind of reading,
and Catholic kind of storing.
When I decided to speak,
I had a lot to say,
and many ways in which
to say what I had to say.
I listened to the black minister,
I listened to the melody of the preachers,
and I could tell when they would start up
♫ On that kind of thing,
♫ When we didn't know they
mean to take our souls
♫ Straight to heaven
or whether they meant to
dash us straight to hell,
I understood it.
So out of this evil, which
was a dire kind of evil,
because rape on the
body of a young person,
more often than not, introduces cynicism.
And there's nothing quite
so tragic, as a young cynic,
because it means the person
has gone from knowing nothing
to believing nothing.
In my case, I was saved in that muteness,
you see,
in the sort of die, I was saved.
And I was able to draw from human thought,
human disappointments and triumphs,
enough to triumph myself.